focus here so far has been on vaccines
donations of injections
to poorer countries certainly from the
us and the uk but your
think tank is suggesting that perhaps
there ought to be
a focus rather closer to home so that
people can start moving around again
those who've had vaccinations with
vaccine passports
well there are two separate things adam
i mean first of all obviously
vaccinating the world is important and
we can vaccinate
probably the most vulnerable the
frontline healthcare workers
and mainly the urban populations
of the developing world even this year
and therefore the announcement
of britain giving vaccines american
giving vaccines others will come in with
their contributions that's really
important so
whatever we're doing back here if we
don't take care of the rest of the world
then
our vaccination program here ultimately
will not protect us
um but yes it's true we're we're also
saying very clearly that
i look i believe there should be a
distinction between those who are
vaccinated those who are unvaccinated
and people who are vaccinated should be
able to enjoy greater freedom to travel
and greater freedom
from restrictions and and most countries
around the world now
are drawing this distinction because if
you are vaccinated fully vaccinated
you're less likely to transmit the
disease
less likely to get it and less likely to
be um
seriously ill so there are two quite
separate things
one is vaccinate the world insofar as we
can as fast as we can
and then what we're doing in our own
country
but isn't concentrating on vaccine
passports
rather unequal rather unfair really
because it will benefit those people
who've had vaccines it won't benefit the
others
and it will take a great deal of energy
to implement it properly and shouldn't
we really be concentrating on the basis
that
we're all in together we're all
threatened by the disease and we
shouldn't be trying to get
you know special privileges for uh some
people over others
yeah i confess i really don't understand
this point
i mean we offer vaccines to everybody
and we offer them
for free i mean okay we go we proceeded
age by age but now over half
the british population is fully
vaccinated i have every sympathy and you
need to make special provision we
suggested how that should be done
for those who have medical reasons for
not being vaccinated but if someone
who's entitled to be vaccinated chooses
not to be vaccinated
that's their choice but we should take
account of the fact that those
who are fully vaccinated are less of a
risk for the disease than those who
aren't and
if you look at what's happening for
example around the world
this distinction is being made i think
it's highly unlikely you're going to get
international travel going again
without people saying if you're coming
into my country we'd like to see proof
of vaccination
and one of the things that i don't know
whether this will be discussed at the g7
but would be sensible to discuss is if
the main countries together
put their collective efforts into
providing
a proper and secure way of doing
international travel
so that there are agreed standards and
agreed verification
of vaccination i think it would be a
hugely important step forward
because in the end the world will have
to get vaccinated
and countries will be reluctant to
welcome you in
if you're not vaccinated
or you don't at least have proof of a
negative test
but i mean who would actually run this
system that is a big problem do you have
any idea
uh they're those people who are saying
that really what this is all about
is you wanting to bring back the idea of
id cards which
didn't go so well when you were prime
minister i happen to think the case for
biometric id as a as actually a
instrument in the hands of citizens to
help them with their daily lives
is overwhelming and i i just make you
this prediction
in years to come most countries will
move in that direction
but no this is simply about vaccination
and other countries are doing it already
if you go to israel or um you know you
get you go to the uae you you will get a
vaccination you actually have a qr code
on your phone it shows the vaccination
and you will show that as you go into
the country
now this uh g7 you've been to a lot of
them in the past
do you think that this is going to
succeed in
convincing the world that globalization
isn't a dirty word
well global cooperation with a global
pandemic is obvious and necessary and i
think
you know the g7 some g7s end up
being what i call communique summits in
other words you issue a communique and
there are warm words but nothing much
happens this summit is really important
it's coming at a really important
juncture
the announcements on vaccines are real
and that's important
i think the g7 will also take action on
um a global surveillance system because
one of the things we need to do
urgently is make sure we're picking up
new variants from around the world
and analyzing them fast and we need to
put in place the surveillance to do that
and also we're going to need to make
sure that even if we get these vaccines
to some of the poorest countries in the
world and my institute works in many of
them
those countries themselves have got to
have the capacity to absorb the vaccines
and roll them out and register them
properly
so you know there's a lot of work to be
done
for this pandemic and then you've got a
whole slew of questions
about how you prepare for future
pandemics so this you know this g7
should be and i think it will be
hopefully a as
a summative substance where there are
real and clear things being decided and
it will also probably lay the ground for
the climate summit happening again in
the uk later in the year
and obviously the big changes in
presidents from trump to biden
but there is there has to be a real
doubt doesn't there as to whether
america really is back as a constructive
international
partner when you look at the political
situation in america the support that
donald trump
still has from the republican party uh
and in congress
i mean this may just be a sort of polite
interlude couldn't
in in continuing tensions particularly
between europeans and the united states
um well it's a it's a you know it's an
interesting point and you're right that
america remains deeply divided
but i think there is a way through this
where you just accept that on certain
issues
and this pandemic's one of them
cooperation
is sensible because we know what the
risk is
i mean why are we now debating pushing
back the 21st of june date
because of the delta variant that's
originated in india
and is now spreading throughout the
world and it will become the dominant
variant
here so it's in our interest that we
help cooperate in order to get the world
vaccinated so that we don't have
more variants arising some of which may
be
completely resistant to vaccine so you
know we've got to hope that that doesn't
happen but what it does is it places
emphasis
on the importance of that global
cooperation so again with climate change
there's no point in one country taking
action unless all countries take action
so i think that the um you know the
what whatever issues there are in
american politics and you're right adam
those divisions are still very deep
nonetheless there are certain questions
upon which plainly
and obviously there's a point in
cooperation
and you know corporation tax and
cooperating on that's another example of
it
so i think there is a real change um and
even if those divisions remain in
america there is a real point to the
cooperation and this summit can give an
impetus to it
now you and john major warned of the
consequences of brexit
for the good friday agreement the
belfast agreement
in northern ireland we have had
brexit we've had the northern irish
protocol clearly
an issue of tension between the uk and
the eu
and now seemingly uh with the biden
administration
as well do you have the answer what what
is the way out of this
what we did actually is an institute
publisher a paper from our team that
that looks at this a few weeks back
suggesting ways through it and i
honestly believe the only way through it
is to get to
the practical situation i mean what
goods are passing from britain to
northern ireland northern ireland
into the republic that's of course still
part of the european union
and how do you differentiate between
them and get the right
you know detailed transactions and and
regulations around them so that you make
sure you're minimizing any friction at
the border
but the fact is there was always going
to be this problem
i mean there's no way that you can take
the uk out of the single market and
customs union of the european union
and not have an issue to do with the
border between the north and south and
ireland because
the north then goes out of the european
union the south remains
in the european union and therefore
you've got a hard border there
so the purpose of the protocol was to
find a way around that
and well it's it's difficult because you
know
it's a it's at one level it's an
irresolvable problem
and i think the only way they're going
to resolve it is to get down to
real sort of brass tacks on the
practical issues
and see where northern ireland can in
any event keep
aligned with european regulation and
where
there may be areas where it really
doesn't matter so much for britain also
to be in line with european regulation
in order to protect that border but the
only way you're going to resolve it you
can't resolve the matter of principle
it's just not possible
because there's a complete inconsistency
between
taking the uk out of the single market
and keeping the board
without friction between north and south
of ireland so you've got to look at
practical solutions instead
but do you agree with the british
government that frankly
the european union has been too
bureaucratic too inflexible too
purist about all of this and as you say
putting principle to one side looking at
the practicalities might be the way to
go
and it's the way that the eu frankly is
resisting
well the the eu would put it the other
way around by the way
um but look i think you there's no point
in going into a negotiation
sort of by megaphone with the other side
you've got to sit down and try and work
it out
but i think there'll be you know
there'll be huge resistance within
europe to scrapping the protocol
because it's not as if the protocol was
negotiated without there being a clear
understanding of what it meant
now as i say i don't think i i don't
think there's any way you're going to
get the protocol scrapped
i think what could happen is that you
find as i said these practical ways
through and let's hope
that that happens because otherwise it
will cause real tension in northern
ireland